after days of protests against sri
lanka's government 17 ministers take
their oath before the president
most are young with little political
experience
the crisis that exists today is a good
opportunity to bring changes to the
system the people are asking for you
have got that opportunity along with
that i am asking young people to assist
that process
sources tell al jazeera that prime
minister mahinda rajapaksa wanted more
experienced people in the cabinet he did
not attend the swearing-in
the president's decision to bring
younger people into the cabinet is seen
by critics as a way of acknowledging and
responding to demands made by youths in
country-wide protests against him and
his government
the country is suffering its worst
economic crisis since independence from
britain in 1948.
a shortage of foreign currency has left
the government unable to import basic
essentials leading to price increases
and shortages of food medicine cooking
gas and fuel
tens of thousands of people have
demonstrated for more than a week at
this protest ground outside the
president's office in colombo
and the reaction to the new cabinet here
was no surprise
it's of no use at all it's the same kind
of crooks just different faces coming in
this is not a solution
we came from karunigala to somehow chase
them out we honestly have no way to live
because of what they are doing we are
managing with great difficulty after
months of denying an economic crisis the
government has downplayed the protests
and is seeking help from the
international monetary fund
but some economies say it may be too
late
most of the young people we spoke to
here say they're not happy with the
appointment of a new cabinet and that as
long as president gotabe rajapaksa and
prime minister mahinda rajapaksa remain
in charge things will be the same
fernandez al jazeera colombo